-Our next guest can be seen
at the Las Vegas Comedy Cellar
February 27th through March 3rd.
Please welcome the very funny
Orlando Leyba.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Alright!
Thank you. Thank you.
Settle down. Thank you.
I'm happy to be here and not at
home watching "Yellowstone."
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. I'm tired of feeling like
less of a man
every time that I watch.
Every time I watch.
For those that don't know,
"Yellowstone" is a TV show
about a cattle ranch ran by
"The Bodyguard" himself,
Kevin Costner.
A man who doesn't want outsiders
moving in, buying up the land,
and turning it
into a Whole Foods.
That's the plot, I think.
[ Laughter ]
Alright?
Streaming now on Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
The acting is great.
But the visuals of "Yellowstone"
are amazing.
I'm in love with Yellowstone.
So imagine my excitement
when my buddy Eric Ladd
invited me to his wedding.
Where? In Yellowstone.
"Are you coming?"
"Oh, I'm there!
I've been watching the show."
[ Laughter ]
The second I landed, guys,
the second I landed, I got it.
This place was so beautiful,
so majestic.
"Is this Narnia?"
I asked the locals.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I understood Kevin Costner.
Shoot, I became Kevin Costner.
[ Laughter ]
By the third day, I was telling
people to get off my land.
[ Laughter ]
Sure, it was at
the hotel courtyard,
but that's the way that I felt.
[ Laughter ]
I couldn't stop saying, "Go on,
get," like my buddy Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
"Go on, get.
Go on -- Go on, get!"
[ Laughter ]
"You go on, get, from that
cucumber water. Go on, get."
[ Laughter ]
"You've had enough of
our minerals, sir.
You've had enough."
I drove out there.
I got to meet real cowboys and
cowgirls, good people working
the land, riding horses,
feeding America.
I got to met those people
and they got to meet me.
Yeah. With my coffee-house
vibes, you know?
[ Laughter ]
I introduced myself.
"Hello, guys.
My name is Orlando.
My pronouns are he and him.
Uh, I have an extra iced matcha
latte made with rice milk."
[ Laughter ]
"It's less aggressive
on your tummy.
Any takers? Any takers?"
There were no takers.
[ Laughter ]
But I was so impressed by
these people,
and they were so ready for me
to get off their land.
[ Laughter ]
So, I drove. I drove into
Yellowstone, and I saw nature.
I'm a city guy and I saw nature.
I saw elks, the real ones with
the coat racks. I saw them.
[ Laughter ]
I saw bears doing bear stuff.
They waved at me.
They waved for real.
Ha! I saw bisons.
Those are real.
[ Laughter ]
I thought bisons were made up
like unicorns, but...
There he was, a bison
in the middle of the road
looking like a bougie cow. Moo.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I know.
I see you, bougie cow.
[ Laughter ]
People honked at it.
And I was like, "No, you don't
do that.
You don't -- You don't honk
at a dinosaur."
[ Laughter ]
I, on the other hand, drove
around it with ease
thanks to my rented Ford F-150.
[ Laughter ]
I only say that in hopes of
getting Ford to give me
a free, fully loaded
F-150 truck.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I drove deeper into Yellowstone
because I had to go see
Old Faithful.
For those that don't know,
Old Faithful is a thermal geyser
that shoots water and steam
into the air
from the middle of the Earth,
"allegedly."
They call it Old Faithful
because it will always go off
right on time,
plus or minus 10 minutes.
When I got there,
this place was packed.
It was packed with people.
They built a whole visiting
center.
I could tell that something was
about to happen,
but I was way in the back.
And I said, "I don't want to
miss Old Faithful."
So I shimmied my way
to the front.
"Excuse me, pardon me,
excuse me.
Go on, get, lady! Excuse me."
[ Laughter ]
And Old Faithful
did not let us down.
Did not let us down.
It went right off on time,
plus 10 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
And when it went off, it shot
so high into the sky,
I had to take a step back.
And I was like, "By God."
It reminded me of me in my 20s.
Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's not me anymore.
Understand that.
I'm more like Old Dependable.
Or Old Maybe Later,
plus or minus 10 days.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright.
I'm going to "go on, get," now.
I'm Orlando. Thank you.
I'm Orlando Leyba.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Orlando Leyba!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, fantastic, buddy.
He'll be at the Las Vegas
Comedy Cellar
February 27th through March 3rd.
We'll be right back, everybody.